is it nice to have the barbs in your
corner
I feel like the barbs [__] with you and
that's a good place to be in and just in
the world they've shown me so much love
and so much support like The Vibes are
like
like who needs a uh
like for Nikki it's like she doesn't
even need a label like sheeps are their
own Army like she just treated last
night because she didn't go to met Galen
she was like number one on trending
Legend
it's crazy because the barbs came to my
defense because I said something about
uh I love Little Kim but I said
something that little Kim's whatever
they're called
they're her barbs and they came at me
crazy for like two days and then the
barbs had my back they're crazy it's
just like a real army what is do you
have a fan base name
it's crazy
um I have titled and title with a couple
names but I think I'm gonna probably
just find one that comes naturally like
yeah yeah have you seen swarm on uh
Amazon Prime yet yes I did it's really
really crazy and it's also kind of like
scary like that it's kind of like not
too far from reality like and it's it's
a little crazy because you don't really
see women serial killers so that was
there was that one movie uh uh monster
with Charlize Theron did you ever watch
that she was a serial killer she was
like a prostitute she used to kill
Truckers
yeah it was a good movie I'm gonna I
know Charlize Theron she's like really
beautiful girls yeah she like took on a
role as like this like white trash like
trucker lady who was like a lot lizard
do you know what a lot lizard is I don't
know what a lot lizard is
so it's a lot lizard
if you're a truck driver
they have truck stops and it's girls who
offer lonely men who are in trucks at
truck stops in the middle of nowhere
certain services so why they call them
lizards that's just what they call them
they call them a lot lizard that is
gross it is gross well it's a dirty name
like I I don't I don't disagree it's an
attorney name or a dirty job
um yo on this record uh you dropped 16
which I think is dope because you're
getting your [__] off on that oh thanks
give me some yo what so what job did you
get fired from
oh man I had like a a job at a like when
I was I had tons of jobs I had every
single job like grocery store bartending
waitressing but it was like a bartending
job I didn't oh yeah it was a bartending
job and you just told me to go [__] them
and Foot Locker too Footlocker yeah but
I had I have a great relationship with
Footlocker like I I I was like employee
of the year really no no no not really
but could could you like were you like
top tier assistant are you back during
any of the shoes no I had keys and
everything I was super responsible like
good employee I was that girl yeah so
you weren't like if the pair of Jordans
came in no I wasn't feeling it no no I'm
not saying stealing but you might set up
a parasite for you for the homie like
you know yeah I did that a few times
yeah yeah I used to do that for my
friends what was the last real job you
had was it the bartending thing yeah
and you just like did you literally tell
them [__] you when you when you got
fired no I didn't actually not that one
um one of them yeah but not not the last
one so you could make a drink like you
could make like a yeah I'm actually like
I can make it I'm really a chef
what can you cook everything literally
everything when you say you're really a
chef what does that mean like the same
do you have like a certificate that says
so
are you just I'm a hood Chef you're a
hood Chef okay yes so what's like the
go-to if I had to be like okay show me
like what is your what are you gonna
make there you're very confident in
um um well what do you like I'm I'm into
everything
I'm a fat [__] as we discussed like I
got some famous dishes of mine like if
you had to cook a dish for uh
give me the Gordon Ramsay dish he's
sitting there all right like I'm a
cookie so I would make it I would make a
medley of things okay because I I feel
as though if I have a medley I can't
lose if you don't like one thing he's
gonna like another thing so I would do
like these um lamb chops that I do these
garlic jar mint lamb chops the mint okay
they very like taste level like
very high like it's not even regular at
all and then I would do a Chilean sea
bass
oh and then
I would do uh on another day if you come
I would do coconut curry chicken and
white rice Jesus that's a famous meal of
mine do people go crazy for you see he's
not in his head people go crazy and the
people go absolutely insane and last but
not least lasagna rolls talk about it
that sounds fire
yo the best Italian food I ever had was
in Boston A Little Italy and there's
like those little bakeries that stay
open all night yeah oh my God cannolis
oh my goodness I miss the cannoli I
began out the [__] club from DJ and
[__] face and there was a [__] Bakery
open at three in the morning like what
the [__] is going on over here I love a
bakery so lasagna rolls